SEAN ROBINSON: When you
see that a student has
an understanding of
what they're doing which
is very different
from what's real,
you try to find
something in what they're
doing that is just very counter
to what their understanding is.
Really point it out.
You have to elicit it.
Make them understand that, hey,
look, this thing over here,
you can see that that's true.
And if that's true,
then your understanding
can't possibly be true.
That gets them into
the mental state
that neuropsychologists
call cognitive dissonance.
And that is a point
where students
are very ripe for learning.
You elicit the
cognitive dissonance
and then help them resolve it.
Those sort of
teaching moments are
things that really stick
with the student for quite
some time.
So for us, in the
course of the semester,
we try to elicit many of these
moments of cognitive dissonance
early in the
semester, and really
try to get them through
these important lessons
of eliminating the very
common misunderstandings
that many people come
into the class having.